this was the scene six months ago in the
Bahamas that person in shorts is of
course FTX founder Sam bankman freed
otherwise known as SPF he's seen here
with Bahamian prime minister Philip
Davis breaking ground at the site set
for ftx's Global headquarters the
arrival and presence of FDX
underscores the Readiness of the Bahamas
to be a home for global leaders in the
crypto space
but now that land sits empty the
celebrated project abandoned so what
made the Bahamas so appealing to FTX in
the first place and what will happen to
the nation's crypto Hub status now that
its biggest player has collapsed
the relationship between FTX and the
Bahamas has
um it's been interesting to watch wsj's
Angel Lao young went to Nassau to cover
the fall of FTX obviously the Bohemian
government wanted companies like FTX to
come to the Bahamas and so it went about
courting these companies it was the
first to issue its National currency in
digital form sand dollar the digital
Bahamian dollar it hosted a crypto
conference presented by FTX welcome to
the Bahamas but most importantly it
enacted a comprehensive legal framework
for digital assets like cryptocurrency
Bahamas is a couple steps ahead in the
U.S of trying to create a regulatory
environment for the industry and that
really boils down to the Dare act that
was passed in the end of 2020.
the digital assets and registered
exchanges act or Dare is intended to
give firms like FTX clear rules to
adhere to before a company especially
that's going to be a digital Exchange
puts its headquarters in a country you
know it wants to have certainty about
how that country is classifying
all these different products that's
attorney Bruce dagaris who's worked on
Caribbean Financial Services matters and
international white-collar crime the
Dare framework he's talking about
doesn't yet exist in the U.S but
regulation is something SPF has called
for the fact that TX wanted to make
their headquarters in the Bahamas it
gave legitimacy to the Dare Act and the
Dare activate legitimacy to FTX however
having regulations and enforcing them
are two different things the financial
action task force our Global Financial
Watchdog has previously put the Bahamas
on its so-called gray list for increased
monitoring the country was only delisted
two years ago the Bahamas regulatory
regime is not as harsh and so most
likely FTX was hoping or maybe even
expecting that the Bahamas would not
partially Implement its direct both FTX
and the Securities Commission of the
Bahamas did not respond to requests for
comment
there's also how the country deals with
taxes last month the European Union
added the Bahamas to its tax Haven
blacklist which identifies jurisdictions
that don't yet comply with all
International tax standards the country
doesn't charge personal capital gains a
state gift or inheritance taxes it also
doesn't have corporate tax unless that
revenue is derived from within the
Bahamas the U.S is known for having high
personal income taxes no matter where
you live I mean you can move to some
states and you might have a lower income
tax rate but nothing beats the Bahamas
so I can see why the Bahamas is a
particularly attractive option to
somebody like SBF who has publicly
stated that he wants to make as much
personal money as possible to give back
to various causes another thing the
Bahamas has going for it it's really
close to the U.S just about an hour
flight to Miami it's very helpful if
you're a company like FTX and you want
to attract U.S business and you want to
do business in the US but yet you don't
want to be subject to all the regulation
and the tax regime fly about two hours
further north and there's DC SPF has
become something of a regular on Capitol
Hill over the last year even testifying
before the Senate on crypto regulation
the uh industry has the potential to
improve a lot of people's lives but now
with ftx's collapse the decision to
headquarter in the Bahamas is
complicating its bankruptcy ftx's new
leadership is at odds with the country's
Regulators over who has control over
billions in customer assets is it going
to be the Bohemian authorities who have
control of these assets
um for the liquidation process or will
the SEC be involved there are still
really big questions on who's going to
be responsible for holding up to X
accountable
it's unclear yet how severely ftx's
collapse will affect the Bahamas but
experts expect that it will harm the
country and its reputation as a crypto
Hub the fact that they've attracted the
number three digital exchange and that
it quickly went from success to
bankruptcy has jeopardized the new
product and the new innovation that the
Bahamas has undertaken unfortunately
ftx's collapse will likely Force the
Bahamas and other governments to look
more closely at the crypto industry for
years now every government has known
that this is an issue that is not going
to go away but with this collapse now
that billions upon billions of customers
money has been lost it's going to force
these governments to enact an
accountability framework much faster
than they might have been willing to do
previously as for SPF it remains to be
seen what action if any the Bahamas
might take against him
[Music]